Kevin Spacey has been acquitted he was
charged with seven counts of sexual
assault and three counts of indecent
assault against four men which is a lot
even by Hollywood standards those are
the sort of numbers even the Catholic
Church would struggle to ignore do you
remember in the 90s when we all wondered
how Kevin Spacey managed to play
predatory Psychopaths so convincingly
then the charges came out and we all
went oh so he's been going method he was
accused by one man of grabbing his
crotch like a cobra it was surprising
cobras don't have hands if Spacey did
attack his crotch like a cobra it would
mean he launched himself head first
across the room and sunk his fans into
the
vampire in unrelated news Kevin Spacey
will be starring in gay vampire six he
needs to pay the legal bill somehow so
anyway Spacey has been found not guilty
in court he remains guilty on Twitter
though
social media is so much more effective
than a court of law why would you have
to wait years to bring a case to court
when you can fire off a tweet plus you
get to look great in the process and if
you're a woman your word is Gospel
remember hashtag believe all women a
Hollywood actress could have claimed she
was touched up by the Easter Bunny and
the bunny would have ended up on the sex
offenders register with Easter canceled
back in 2017 when he was first accused
no one believed Kevin Spacey was
innocent because he has Shifty little
eyes and when he got charged he came out
as gay do you remember that time Spacey
got mugged at 4 30 a.m in a London Park
when he was walking the dog he changed
his story 17 times before going public
and saying he got tricked into handing
over his phone and then he hit his head
by falling over his dog I don't think
that's the type of head Kevin was
looking for serves him right what Corner
44 year old tries to get laid in a park
at 4 30 a.m why is he not in bed fast
asleep next to someone he despises like
a normal person weird I would have
looked him up just for that but
seriously I'm delighted that Spacey's
been acquitted I'm gonna celebrate by
watching him play a predatory psychopath
in seven
spoiler alert his character was
eventually caught but not before
decapitating Gwyneth Paltrow and
silencing her forever no one's all bad
are they Spacey's charges were part of
the metoo movement which brought down
Harvey Weinstein I'm glad he paid the
price for his behavior he was accused of
masturbating into a plant pot
now I like a nice bunch of roses as much
as the next bloke I'm just saying that
sort of behavior will get you banned
from the Chelsea flower show anyway
Kevin Spacey is finally free to go off
and grab Life by the Bulls like a cobra
foreign